o uso foi o general chinês que viveu
antes de cristo e que venha a ser
inspiração para o livro a arte da guerra
e um dos ensinamentos de azul e um dos
seus ensinamentos
ele diz o seguinte conheça seu
adversário e assim mesmo e em 10
batalhas não conhecer as a derrota o
povo primeiro ponto é a gente conhecer o
alvo
você tem que conhecer o seu alvo o seu
objetivo
eu tenho que ser claro e tem que ser bem
específico você tem que saber exatamente
aquilo que você quer
uma vez definido ao você tem que
conhecer a você mesmo e aí baseados no
seu autoconhecimento
a gente vai para a terceira etapa que é
medir a distância entre você e o seu
objetivo
e aí de acordo com as suas
características
você vai determinar as ferramentas que
você tem em mãos para atingir seu
objetivo
recentemente um filme brasileiro e
chamou muita atenção com relação ao
planejamento estratégico nesse filme o
capitão ele fala pra sua tropa que o
policial não entra na favela atirando
ele entra com estratégia e até
aproveitando que nós estamos falando né
com relação à aciu
eu gostaria de dizer a vocês que
05 o seu estatuto mindu na minha da
minha palestra 05 05 com licença gente
só sabe o que é isso assim dizer uma
granada por gentileza entregue os seus
05 e destrava o pino da granada 05 só
saltar essa granada
sou dormir de novo ela vai cair vai se
explodir vai explodir os seus
companheiros
o senhor vai explodir seul 05 só vai
dormir de novo na minha palestra
então a gente pode ficar tranqüilos né a
granada de brinquedo
muito obrigado a participação do
exército e eu quero dizer a vocês que o
objetivo
o alvo era chamar a atenção de vocês
isto é estratégia então o planejamento
estratégico mudou a minha vida e eu
acredito que pode mudar a sua também
eu passo agora a falar um pouco da nossa
história da nossa luta pela reintegração
como foi que a gente conseguiu né
é é uma das maiores vitórias da classe
trabalhadora desse país
meu nome é clésio fui demitido no
governo collor e reintegrado aos quadros
do governo
vinte anos depois como nós conseguimos
isso como aconteceu o que o que a gente
tinha na mão que nós tínhamos na mão
nós tínhamos uma lei federal
de anistia que não era cumprida nós
tínhamos uma coordenação nacional em
brasília representando as categorias
desconectada com a base
nós tínhamos todos os anistiados na
nossa categoria dispersos desanimados
sem perspectiva de futuro e em alguns
casos sempre esqueço perspectiva de vida
como juntar tudo isso como fazer disso
uma força em 98/99 eu participei de uma
assembléia e nessa assembléia ver o meia
dúzia de de colegas meus que acreditavam
ser possível acontecer
a anistia e aí o vereador nos levou até
brasília e nós tivemos encontro com o
primeiro senador
e esse conto foi determinante
foi muito bom foi determinante porque a
gente pôde perceber que nós não tínhamos
nenhum documento nenhuma organização
nós só tínhamos a vontade quando
voltamos a reunir de novo lá outra
assembléia e passamos para os
companheiros que realmente seria
possível conseguir anistia
baseado no que o senador havia nos dito
aí começou a nossa virada
sabíamos que sólidos conseguiríamos
recursos financeiros e força política
para atingir nosso objetivo e eu sempre
gosto de falar no plural porque foi um
trabalho de equipe
eu não trabalhei sozinho dentro do grupo
a minha função era de articulação
política eu era o articulador político
mas cada um tem a sua função cada um
contribuir com o seu talento e então nós
tivemos a ideia primeira idéia é
primeiro nós precisamos convocar a
categoria e fizemos uma convocatória e
aproveitando a amizade que eu tinha com
os radialistas com a classe é com a
imprensa que na verdade ele era um amigo
do meu irmão que é músico e da minha
irmã que é jornalista
eu peguei uma carona aproveitando isso
nós fizemos uma convocatória e abril os
microfones das rádios e a convocatória
foi da seguinte forma estamos vencendo
anistia
a associação havia uma associação que
estava nos apoiando a associação convoca
todos os anistiados demitidos da estatal
demitidos no governo collor para uma
assembléia na câmara de vereadores no
dia tal na hora tal importante estejam
munidos de documentos
aquele é aquela pessoa que não se fizer
presente
envie o motivo né e enviar representante
legal observação
aquele que não se fizer presente e não
mandar representante legal terá o seu
direito tenham selado
bom gente
para nossa satisfação para nossa
surpresa foi a assembléia com maior
número de anistiados
nós tivemos e aí nós percebemos duas
coisas a primeira
o que havíamos desenvolvido o sonho há
muitas pessoas e em alguns casos em
especial havia devolvido à vida
o onu que não sonha está morto e a
segunda coisa que nós percebemos depois
dessa junção de forças é que havíamos
conseguido na nossa região força
política e recursos financeiros vindos
da própria categoria visto que cada um
passou a contribuir dentro da sua
possibilidade de a gente fez uma
caixinha formou um bolo ea partir daí
nós já tínhamos recurso financeiro e
força política foi o princípio da nossa
virada mas ainda faltava o principal
ainda faltava o alvo
precisávamos e reconhecidos
politicamente em brasília
como fazer
tivemos a segunda ideia foi assim
por várias vezes a segunda idéia é
conectar com o segundo senador
só que dessa vez por nós mesmos vamos
fazer isso a própria categoria
mobilizada chegando
buscando sua força política no brasil
o articulador político
sobrou nenhuma duas 20 v
professor do senador e ele sempre me
dizia olha o infelizmente não tem não
tem espaço na agenda do senador não tem
espaço pau na vigésima vez que eu liguei
eu liguei e coloquei da seguinte forma o
doutor é portar disse olha eu estou
ligando só comunicar o senhor que no dia
tal estaremos em brasília e que nós
vamos arrombar a porta do gabinete do
senador juntamente com a empresa mineira
e vamos dizer ao povo de minas do
senador não recebe mineiro em brasília
meia hora depois você só me liga
o clash o mengão rapaz conseguiu espaço
na agenda do senador
isto é estratégia
gostaria de dizer a vocês que começamos
do nada
não tínhamos literalmente nada e
conseguimos recursos financeiros força
política reconhecimento político em
brasília e principalmente conseguimos
anunciar e reintegrar todos os
companheiros mas eu quero dizer para
vocês que o nada
também é uma ferramenta visto quem
física por várias vezes se a gente parte
1.0 ao ponto determinante
daí vem a questão da distância da
velocidade e do tempo de percurso
e dizer a vocês que o planejamento
estratégico muda uma empresa um estado
um país uma família e ações como essa
muda uma nação
muda o brasil
muito obrigado